So looking at the movie scene capture in Sequencer,
so there's a legacy tool which we're deprecating.
It's really good for rendering videos for AVI
and the general purpose capture for cinematic output.
So it supports custom render passes, HDR exporting,
but it doesn't support high resolution rendering.
So currently still the only option for exporting
self-contained AVI files, but that may change.
So from the drop down here,
you can see that the movie scene capture tool
can still be used.
You've got some of your settings here.
Again, it outputs an AVI file,
but we are moving over to the movie render queue.
So just in case you wanted to use the legacy tool,
it was worth highlighting there.
And then also the HDR exporting,
so you can export HDR data in open EXI files.
So you can specify a HDR compression quality,
and then also specify the capture gamut.
So whether it's Rec.709, the P3D65,
or even the more recent Rec.2020 and the ACES,
and the ACES-CG, and render passes,
the limited render pass option is not rendered layers.
So at least one of the render passes must be selected,
or all render passes options will be rendered.
So again, you've got your settings here
that you can adjust for the movie render settings.
It's worth digging into some of the different options
that you wanna capture here.
And then also when referencing the capture gamut
that you need to specify,
that's in this section down below.